- I did it. I finally did it.
Andrew Reid won a Super Bowl!!!
- What a fun, easy sport.
- I'm telling you all, this has happened before. Look.
- [Phone speaker:] Andrew Reid won a Super—
- OK, time for that darkness retreat.
- We are stuck in a script of a show that just keeps repeating itself.
And its name is—
I wish I could see things clearly.
- Try this. It's a little untraditional.
- Say no more.
Well, guess I'll go die on the Jets with my Wrangler jeans.
Woah, some drink.
- What's he smokin', huh?
[Laugh track playing]
- Expired Gatorade from when I was in St. Louis.
- Back to work!
JK, maybe this year I'll go back to work.
[Awww]
- LOL!
- Is it always like this?
- B.O.B., will you be my O.C.?
- Woah.
- Can't wait to definitely play football this year.
- Stefon Diggs is disgruntled.
- Finally, one of my conspiracy theories is true.
- Welcome, remember to dress up as your—
- They're reusing scripts! We already did a whole Brady thing.
- [Together:] Oh, yeah.
- We're not trapped!
Next year will be the Bills' year.
- Next year will be the Bills' year.
- Oh, my gosh, he's right.
Wait, where's Aaron?
- People will come looking for me if I miss McAfee!
Woah, a secret door.
- Aaron, I'm so sorry I left you.
- I know now...it wasn't your fault.
[Paper printing]
- It's next year's scripts.
Saquon joins the Chiefs?
OK, don't hate that one.
- Hello, I am the Script Writer.
I decide which storylines are epic enough to happen.
- But free will! Why are you repeating everything?
- OMG, spectacular catch, Davante.
The thing is, people only want the same six scripts.
Chiefs good. Refs bad.
Chargers lost in a weird way.
- [Together:] But we wanna win.
- Then press the fire emoji.
Destroy the next 100 years of football scripts.
Choose chaos. That is, if you think that's what people really want.
- F--k you, script writers.
- Timeout! I like the routine.
I underperform one year. I overperform the next.
I get paid. Repeat.
- But, Kirk, don't you wanna win?
- I'm not sure I can.
- Do you know why I'm so confident?
- The cigar?
- Cuz you're really good at football?
- Cuz you're super hot?
- Because when the abyss stares at me,
I stare it the f--k back.
- Kirk, I believe a lot of wacky things.
But I have to believe any of us, even you, could win.
[Beeping]
[Alarm sounding]
- Deleting scripts for Seasons 8-100.
- [Josh Allen:] Wheeee!
- Alright, time to approve next year's scripts.
What? Where are the scripts?
Davante and Aaron need to get back together,
Clammy was supposed to come back in a big way.
We were finally gonna do an Avengers Endgame parody.
Every episode was gonna go so viral!
No! The unknown!
Anything can happen! Oh, god, what if the Lions are good?